hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well okay
so
aristotle says that there's some things
that can get you off the hook
for doing actions that that otherwise
you'd get blamed for or criticized for
and you could say well i didn't know and
people make this sort of excuse a lot
so you also you don't want to just like
do a blanket thing and say well anytime
somebody
can say they don't know we're going to
give them the benefit of the doubt and
say
okay nobody's responsible aristotle does
want to hold people responsible but he
also wants to be
realistic about the degree of
responsibility that we contribute to
them
so one way to think about this right off
the bat
that aristotle looks at is are they
ignorant of
general matters you know sort of global
ignorance about things that are
important in moral life
or is it particular kinds of things that
they're ignorant about
the specifics of the situation
aristotle says that if a person is
actually ignorant of
general matters then it's probably
because
they actually have a vice we've talked
about this a little bit before
and he talks about this in the ethics
that if you have a vice part of what it
does to you
is it blinds you to what's good and
what's bad
it gives you a distorted idea about
what's good so if we just take a few
examples
of the vices that arise talks about a
greedy person
a person who characteristically takes
more than their fair share so
justice is the middle thing greed is on
the the other side
a greedy person may be greedy
and tell themselves hey i like being you
know i like having more than everybody
else
um and they know that it's wrong but
usually
how do they talk about it they say oh no
that's that's the right share for me
everybody else should get less i deserve
more
um or they'll say things like everybody
should be greedy
well you know you'd have your fair share
too if you were greedy like me and you
you actually
they don't call it greed they'll say if
you were ambitious or a go-getter
or however you want to put it well
aristotle would say that person has a
distorted idea
about general moral matters they don't
actually realize that greed is bad they
think that greed is good or if you take
anger
aristotle spends a lot of time talking
about different problems with anger
the person who characteristically gets
angry
quicker than they should and stays angry
or longer than they should and spills
over to affect other people
every once in a while they'll come along
and they'll say yeah i've got a problem
i've got to go to anger management but
do you think most people go to anger
management because they choose to go to
anger management
who actually makes them go usually
the judge yeah court appointed
or you know their spouse says hey you
know if if you don't go to anger
management
we're we're done so somebody actually
has to come along and say
you're mistaken about some really
fundamental things your mind is screwed
up
you need to get your head straight and
then they can go and try to work on that
but until then they're ignorant about
some things they
actually think that that getting angry
to the sort of things that they do
is the right response and staying angry
as long as they they want to stay angry
is a good thing
so aristotle says if that's the case
you're actually responsible for that
because how do we become virtuous or
vicious
through our choices now once you
actually are
vicious if you have a vice
you can't just snap your fingers and say
okay i'm not going to see things this
way i'm not going to act this way
anymore some of you may have tried this
with some things in the past it doesn't
really work you have to work on it
over time change your habits change your
way of looking at things
get new models sometimes get new friends
and
sometimes it takes a lot of work that
can change the way in which you see
things that can make you no longer
ignorant of general matters but until
then the vicious person is going to be
ignorant of some important general
matters i put some examples here
this kind of action is right or wrong
you know the greedy person thinks that
it's good to behave
in a greedy way it's good to indulge
their their desires as much as they want
likewise they think that certain things
are wrong that are actually right
like giving everybody their fair share
they think that's for suckers
um or you know this good is to be
preferred to that one
another type of greedy person we we use
greed in enough a couple different ways
if you think about somebody who's stingy
right they don't want to spend
money or resources for other people
including sometimes their own family
the the virtue that they should have is
generosity
generosity doesn't mean you just give
and give and give and give it means you
give to the right people
at the right time for the right reasons
you don't want to be at the other
extreme where you're just taking
advantage of all the time
you give everything away and then you've
got nothing
but you don't want to be stingy either
the stingy person though
when they're behaving in a stingy way do
you think they say to themselves
i know that being stingy is bad but i
want to be like this
no they say this is the good thing to do
all these other people they're crazy
look at how much money they blow on
things i'm just being prudent
i'm putting away money for things
that'll be truly valuable
and what do they do they end up valuing
money as a good
money is a good right but they end up
valuing it
much more highly than other things like
say relationships which which are
a more important good than money
or um good reputation even good
reputation is in certain ways a better
thing from an aristotelian perspective
than money
or pleasure they deprive themselves of a
lot of pleasures
pleasures are good too right sometimes
you should spend money
on yourself to enjoy yourself so
ignorance of general matters aristotle
thinks you're responsible for that
now we could debate that you know what
if somebody grows up in a society
where everybody's screwed up say in a
very violent society
if we want to use anger a very
aggressive society where everybody
fights all the time well then aristotle
would say that person is
pretty much stuck they're going to be
vicious
and we could debate about how
responsible they are you know for
cultural things like that um but what we
really want to look at is
particulars that would get us out of um
responsibility so aristotle says
when somebody commits an act out of
ignorance and it's involuntary
typically afterwards they feel bad about
it somebody who feels
you know that what they did was a-okay
that's different but these are the
things that people often get screwed up
with particular
elements of the situation and then they
feel bad they say i just didn't know
that
i didn't realize in this situation i'll
give you an example
um i once injured a kid
by by a mistake i was working in a gas
station
and this guy drove off without paying so
i go you know
bursting out the door and there's a kid
like standing right by the door
and you know push the door to go chase
this guy
the door hit the kid didn't didn't
really you know hurt him
in any permanent way but you know scared
scared the kid and knocked him down
and because mom was real mad at me
you know and i and i was saying i got to
get you know this this
guy's license plate because i'm
responsible for
her doing that well i felt bad about it
you know i don't like hurting kids i
don't really like hurting anybody but
you know kids especially
and um what can i claim it well
i didn't know some of these factors of
the situation
there were certain things escaping my my
purview and why because we're human
right we don't take in
everything possible have you ever hurt
somebody by mistake
i think all of you probably have right
either not necessarily physically but
perhaps emotionally
what are the things that we can be less
conscious or ignorant or mistaken about
aristotle says the doer who's at who's
actually the agent in this case
pretty rare for for most people
but if you were you know sort of
out of your mind i suppose that could be
the case so we're not going to worry
that much about that
the act what you're actually doing
sometimes you know the same act can be
described a couple different ways
so keeping a secret
or keeping a confidence that a friend is
made to you
that sounds like a good thing right
um
what if you don't really realize the
implications of what your friend is
is asking you to keep silent about
and then something bad happens are you
responsible
for it well again you didn't you weren't
completely
cognizant of what was going on um
the thing affected aristotle has some
some examples
that he gives of these that are kind of
good
some of them are a little bit uh silly
but
some aren't um
yeah here we go he says a person might
mistake his his son for an enemy
um when do situations like that happen
home defense right people get sometimes
injured or shot
other things along those lines happen
because somebody just didn't realize
what was being affected
are there are there other cases where
you might not be completely cognizant of
everything that's that's in the
situation
where that can happen you can probably
think of a lot of cases like that
um here's an interesting case
how about food allergies are all of you
completely aware of all your friends
food allergies
food allergies are pretty serious aren't
they i mean if somebody's got a peanut
allergy
and they like go into anaphylactic shock
i think that's the right way to say all
right
that's pretty scary and all it takes is
like you know a little bit of
a peanut to do that or somebody has
celiac disease
and so they're you know they can't have
gluten and you give them something and
you don't even even realize that it has
any gluten because it's a processed food
or something
along those lines
they get very sick
very painful
now if that happens you know because you
gave your friend a candy bar
or made a nice drink for them or
something like that
are you are you responsible for that did
you choose
to make them sick no your ignorance
of the thing affected the friend right
the instrument he has an example here
that's a little bit harder to relate to
he says you might mistake a sharp sphere
for
one with a button on it people used to
practice
fighting with with weapons that had you
know blunted edges
or would have like a little ball on it
there's actually those of you who've
read hamlet there's a there's a famous
part of the the last scene where they
think that
hamlet thinks that they're they're
fencing with blunted foils
but they're actually sharp foils
does this sort of thing happen not so
much with weapons
in our society what what what are the
sort of things that happen like that
where
somebody thinks they're working with one
thing and it turns out to be a different
kind of thing
and then something bad happens can you
think of any examples
i think computers might offer us a lot
of examples
people what's that people okay people in
one sense um like working in the field
that i work in somebody might come in
with a situation
where they're not going to school okay
so you're addressing but not going to
school piece
yeah but really in actuality have to do
with the fact that there's a
stable life mom is up all night so he
can't get up to get to school on time
so as you start to look at delve into it
it's not really about him not going to
school it's about what's going on at
home
yeah that probably wouldn't be the
instrument that would be more likely
some of these other
factors like the act
the thing affected um you choose what
remedies you want to
do i don't know your friend lets you
drive this car
you think it's a fast car but he didn't
tell you it is turbo
okay yeah that's a great example
the hammer down and uh suddenly you're
at 60 miles per hour in in
six seconds and you know you're wrapped
around the stop sign or something
well you wouldn't be right you'd
telephone post or something yeah okay
that's a good example a car that's too
fast
same thing could happen with a car
that's too slow you know you're used to
a car
that actually has some pickup and you're
trying to get onto a very busy
on-ramp and people are flying by
including truckers at 70 miles per hour
and so you're like you know just
puttering up there at 50 miles an hour
you've got it down all the way but that
car isn't going any faster than
boom somebody hits you from behind well
you didn't know right or there could be
other things wrong with
the car as well the brakes go out but
you didn't know that the brakes were
going to go out
yeah cars are a pretty good example for
instruments
the effect there are many times where
we're
intending to do something but we're not
intending to do the thing that actually
happens
he has a an example here which again
doesn't happen too often one might kill
a man by giving him medicine with the
intention of saving his life
but you know this sometimes we give
people medicine and they turn out turn
out to have an allergy to it right
you know i know some people that are
allergic to penicillin
and if you give it a penicillin which is
generally good
you'll kill them now if you're a doctor
and that's not in their chart
and you give them the penicillin
and you know you presume that it would
be in their chart if
they actually had an allergy you weren't
intending that effect were you
you were intending to do something else
to heal them
are there other examples of that sort of
thing have you ever heard somebody by
saying something to them
that you had no intention of hurting
them with
you had no idea was going to hurt them
what are what are some examples of that
without getting too you know
too revealing
i'll give you an example from my
childhood um
my dad was a pretty tough guy and
i didn't realize that he was sort of
sharing something with me that was was a
sore spot for him i remember him showing
me his high school pictures
and he had big ears that kind of stuck
out the way a lot of kids do
at that age and he said that the other
kids called him dumbo
and he was confiding something in me
that
yeah i don't think he he thought i would
do anything with so of course i started
calling him dumbo
and i was you know like eight nine years
old
and you know kids that age kind of poke
at people right
you guys remember that age some of you
may still you know have friends that do
that at this age
um no i didn't intend to really hurt my
dad's feelings
it really hurt it
i had no idea it was going to do that i
thought we were just joking around
um i wasn't intending that effect
probably if he had known i was going to
do that he wouldn't show me that picture
and told me that story either
have any of you ever done anything like
that before
hurt somebody's feelings and you had no
idea you were going to hurt their fans
i mean it's very difficult to to know
the entire history of a person and where
all of their vulnerabilities lie and
what might set them off isn't it yeah i
mean after you after you get to know
them for a while
you've probably actually triggered a few
of them so you know to stay away from
those
it doesn't work like when my wife asked
me how do i look
yeah that's a bad question no matter
what you say you lose
generally yeah um are there any other
questions like
like that loaded questions we call those
do you love me
yeah or who do you like better me or
that person um
yeah now the other thing that he talks
about is manner
the way in which we're doing something
and here he has an example of somebody
who
doesn't know their own strength
or he says in loose wrestling he hits
the person to blow and meaning only to
grip their hand
is it possible to do things in such a
way that you don't realize that it's
actually
damaging or setting off some sort of
train of events that you didn't intend
yeah i mean think about again when
you're talking with somebody
think about kids how many of you have
had babies
babysit or or you've got a younger
brother or sister
or nephews or nieces or
things like that is it is it easy to
like you know when they get out of hand
to try to rein them in is it easy to
hurt their feelings
you raise your voice you don't realize
how loud you're talking to them
has this ever happened yeah
well you know that's that's a matter of
manner or the way in which you're doing
something
when you've gotten angry at somebody
else anger tends to get away from us
and we don't realize just how mean we
look
when we're talking to the other person
how much were our body language is
pushing them away
is that is that voluntary is that
intentional we're not actually
it's a good idea to look in the mirror
sometimes when you're angry so you can
see just what you look like when you're
angry
with another person or have somebody
videotape you or you know use your
voice memo thing on your phone to see
what you sound like because then you get
a little bit of perspective
otherwise you may not realize the manner
in which you're doing
something could it be on the other side
could you be trying to bring about a
certain effect
maybe to correct somebody to get them to
to quit acting in a certain way
and you talk to them in a way that you
think is very strict very firm
but it doesn't actually come across
i think all of you probably had that
experience at one time or another
talking to somebody who
was bothering you and you thought you
were being really firm and then you
realized no i gotta get a i gotta go a
bit further with this person
well that was a matter of manner
so aristotle says if you're ignorant of
these things
then that can get you off the hook
because somebody else is ignorant of
those things
then that can get them off the hook it
doesn't mean a bad thing that hasn't
happened if something
actually took place you know if a car
hit another car
because the person didn't realize just
how powerful it was
there was still an accident there's
still damage right but we don't say that
the person is as responsible we don't
say it was something that was
volunteering on their part
when it comes to murder we make a
distinction between premeditated murder
right murder one we often call it
murder carried out in a heat of passion
the murder too and then if we want to
drop it further what do we go to
manslaughter yeah and manslaughter we
don't say that's murder right we say
there's a different degree of
culpability the person is still
responsible for having taken a human
life
but they weren't intending it now you
can say well shouldn't they have known
better
you know could there have been
negligence and there can be negligence
with these things
aristotle talks about the difference
between acting
from ignorance and acting in the
ignorance
we're responsible for one we're not
responsible for the other
if somebody else is responsible for you
not knowing these things
then you're not responsible for that
right they are responsible for that
maybe they didn't know that not giving
you the information would bring about
the effects and then they could be
you know off the hook as well are there
ways in which you can make yourself
ignorant
of these sorts of things by not paying
attention by deliberately
looking away what do you think
how many of you have seen friends who um
they're in a bad relationship
and deep in their heart they know it's a
bad relationship
and you're you know talking to them
every week and you're like you got to
break up with that person
you know i mean look what they did now
um
and they're and they're always you know
finding well no no they
they really love me they they made it up
to me
they're not gonna do it again blah blah
blah blah blah right
um
they cheated on you well you know
no no i i don't think they really did um
i think that you know they weren't
actually cheating on me they didn't act
right
they weren't cheating on me they were
they were seduced by somebody else
or they didn't realize that that you
know
that person wasn't me or you know pick
whatever you like right
after a certain point that person is
responsible for their degree of
ignorance aren't they
they're choosing to be blind to the
other person's faults
that's kind of an extreme case but are
there other cases where people
choose not to see these kind of factors
maybe where they're getting something
out of it by not paying attention to
these things
you know things are easier for them
they're getting something they desire
are there other things that you can do
to yourself which would make you
less likely to be conscious of these
things
can you think of any things you might
take say for example
or consume drugs yeah exactly
and aristotle talks about of course you
know there weren't a lot of drugs in his
time so he talks just about drinking
but um it would go the same for drugs if
you
um you know if you get drunk
and then you go out and drive and you
hit something they're not going to say
oh well
no harm no foul you didn't realize that
there was a pedestrian crossing the
crosswalk
crosswalk because you were you were
blind drunk so you didn't
actually know the thing affected and
maybe you thought you were in a you know
slower car or something like that
they're going to say hey you were
drinking
you chose to drink you put yourself in
that
impaired situation likewise for drugs
right
um my wife actually sent me an
interesting thing from seattle
you know because marijuana is legal out
there so now they're
actually putting all these signs just
like we have the drunk driving signs
they have these things about driving
impaired under the influence of pot
because that slows your reaction time
down too right it makes you a little bit
less
liable to good judgments other drugs
might affect you
in other ways pcp makes people
very aggressive and they don't feel a
lot of pain
math makes people really wild
so does coke so now if that person is
choosing to take the drug
and they end up being ignorant of some
things because of the drug
they're responsible for that aristotle
would say
um what if they're the kind of person
who just doesn't pay attention to things
aristotle considers that he says maybe
somebody will say
well this person didn't notice these
things because they're just that kind of
person they just don't pay attention to
things
well you know maybe as a kid that can
fly but at a certain point don't you
become responsible for the degree of
attention that you paid to things
it'd be different if if we're talking
about something like add
you know genuine add not the highly over
diagnosed add that we give to
just about anybody who doesn't want to
pay attention but
there are some people who genuinely have
a organic problem with paying attention
if that were the case then then you
wouldn't be responsible
but if it's because you just have you
know habits of not paying attention to
things
because you know other people have
stepped in and done that for you
well then aristotle would say that you
would be responsible for that that would
be
not acting from ignorance that other
people have caused
that would be acting from ignorance that
you're the cause
so something that aristotle doesn't
actually spell out with this
but i think is worth sort of ending on
is we're responsible to some degree
for how well we pay attention to things
we're responsible for getting things
right
in general matters of moral life and
we're also responsible for
paying attention as best as we can to
the particulars of the situation
if somebody's deceiving us
particularly if they're very good at
deceiving we're not responsible for that
you know
we tend to get deceived about these sort
of things right
if circumstances just kept us from being
able to have access to the information
we're not responsible for that if
there's something wrong with us
organically
you know i mean sometimes when you have
a cold it's harder to pay attention
isn't it
i remember being sick and going to class
and not
being able to remember a thing
afterwards
then you wouldn't be responsible for
that but if you've placed yourself in
those sort of circumstances if
for instance let's say you knew that
somebody's very deceptive and you
you go along with them anyway then you
might be to some degree responsible for
it
so that's where we'll leave off with
this